تاتي هذه التطورات بعد ساعات من اعلان
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احباط محاوله
اوكرانيه لتنفيذ هجوم بواسطه مسيرتين على
العاصمه موسكو وضواحيها وقالت الوزاره في
بيان انه تم اسقاط مستجالتين بواسطه انظمه
الدفاع الجوي مشيره الى ان الحادثه لم
يسفر عن وقوع اصابات او اضرار ماديه من
جهته اعلن عمده
موسكويرتين في منطقه
والاخرى قرب طريق منسك السريع
في الاثناء قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها قتلت 60 عسكريا اوكرانيا ودمرت اليات
عسكريه خلال صدها هجمات اوكرانيه باتجاه
الايمان
لهجوم بمروحيات عسكريه قالت انه استهدف
مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه لمان وادى
الى تدمير مدرعات ومراكز قياده ومراقبه
للقوات الاوكرانيه
على الجانب الاوكراني قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه شنت هجمات
بصاروخ مجنح ونفذ الثلاثه وخمسين غاره
جويه خلال الساعات الاربع والعشرين
الماضيه
اطلقت 86 مقذوفا من راجمات الصواريخ ادى
الى مقتل واصابه عدد من المدنيين والحاق
اضرار بمنشات مدنيه واخرى للبنيه التحتيه
كما اشارت الى ان الطائرات الاوكرانيه
نفذت 10 غارات على مواقع للقوات الروسيه
هيئه الاركان اكدت ان قوتها صدت هجمات
روسيه في مقاطعه دونيتسك وهجمات في محوري
ميلوتوبل وبريديانس بمقاطعه